what about you Connor is there any goals
at all aside from just make cool stuff I
don't know something specific and rank
irony yeah I think uh I don't know in my
mind Big Goal big lofty goals you make
at the start of the year yeah I just
sort of setting yourself up for
disappointment a lot of the times I find
I think some people sorry it's not like
it was a [ __ ] vomiting I think some
people they help and some people they're
detrimental I'm sure you've known many
people who've been like I'm gonna do
this and like they'd never ever do
anything they ever say ever I'm sure you
know people of course okay okay let let
me let me rephrase the question sure
sure is there anything you're excited to
do yeah excited about in 2023 yeah yeah
I sometimes I don't want to say exactly
yeah okay
there's a few things I really want to do
there's a Direction I want to go with
maybe some live stuff that I really want
to try and make happen get off the
ground
um I think I just wanna I'm always
looking to evolve my content because
that's how I get like personal
fulfillment uh making something cool and
having a great time doing it where yeah
everyone wins like the viewer the I have
a good time people working on it have a
great time yeah that's that's what I you
know really really uh Chase um and I
think gaming for me is like a great
relax and it's something I always always
loved my entire lives and if I can find
a good game that I love and I don't feel
bad about playing that's a win too it's
it's like I'm looking for little wins
all across the board right I'll take any
W I can follow the small dogs yes I
wanna you know I actually want to spend
more time with family this year oh yeah
I due to covet I really get spend a lot
of time with them even this year I've
only got to sell them like once yeah in
the entire year like one day
um and so yeah
one day yeah I've only seen them one day
yeah um because of I covered [ __ ] that
happened yeah and you know I really want
to spend more time with them um I also
want to just I really want to just
miscellaneously get good good at weird
stuff I really want to get a motorcycle
license for no reason
just go to the UK I have thought about
getting like so like so like I realized
it's like okay well I I I'm often not
when I go and spend time with my family
and this is my brain Min maxing right
I'm like I'm like oh well sometimes like
I you know during the day they're doing
their own thing and I'm doing my own
thing and then we just kind of we all
hang out in the evenings and we all have
their family time and I realized oh I'd
probably just go back do this like four
five day motorcycle course and during
the day and then hang out with them in
the evening I was like oh that sounds
awesome
maxing family gatherings but no I'm
singing I'm like because I want to do
that and I'm like oh this makes sense
because I want to do it in the UK as
well yeah I'm like oh I could kill two
birds with one stone I don't know why I
want to get a I have no desire to
actually like ride motorcycles often I'm
like that would just be cool to have and
also I actually would like to ride some
mopeds in Japan and other motorcycles
yeah I have thought about getting a
moped license in Japan just be like it'd
be nice to just like you know if I had
like a couple of hours free just jump on
a mop and just go somewhere yeah like
weak mopeds you can um I think you don't
need any particular training for in
Japan I can't remember you okay so
something I know I looked into this if
in Japan if you want to get like if you
want to ride like those not a motorcycle
motorcycle you have to go to like an
actual yeah but like the actual like
scooters you can just all you have to do
is just like go to a place uh and you
can just take an online test I think
because the the depends on the CC of the
vehicle how powerful and you can just
take an online test for like 50 bucks or
something and if you pass you get the
license immediately because you also we
want to do more big things as well and I
thought oh it could be really cool if we
had like you know we did some kind of
content that evolved around modes of
transport and if you know if I could
ride any type of motorcycles yeah okay
cool well this feels weird I'm like
isn't that sick that you can just get
you can only acquire this like skills I
think it's awesome
it's collecting the chaos emeralds
particularly I don't particularly like
like there could not be a more gamer way
to say it you can just acquire skills
like it's like hey guys I kind of
discovered it life has a skill I think I
think that we're a lot of the times
people have don't have the time don't
have the money they don't have the the
need to want to learn some of these more
odd skills yeah or not common skills I
just thought oh well you know an
opposition we're extremely lucky and I
feel like I should learn just can't
constantly be trying to learn new skills
that it can be useful I feel like if I
it's a five days of my life and then I
can ride motorcycles the rest of my life
that's pretty [ __ ] sick yeah yeah
like that'd be kind of nice like and
they thought about stuff like that and
I'm like oh man would be cool to be able
to drive a truck I don't even know what
I want to drive a truck but I'm like
that'd be sick to be able to do it just
to say you can could you imagine it I'm
like boys Boss by the way I'll drive it
like that'd be awesome like I just it's
like that one it's like that one person
you know that just has every type of
license yeah and you don't need every
type of like I have no desire for this
is it weird that I want to do it I think
so but I also think that like it's it's
like a pilot's license as well that's
well that's that's way more work that's
not like if it's something you could do
within x amount of days I'm like oh yeah
[ __ ] it let's do it like why not Conor's
like kind of like Min maxing skill trees
it's like yeah what's the what's the
most skills I can acquire for the least
amount of extra space oh right like
there's so many things out there that
are like very like not that hard to kind
of be able to do and then you know you
you could do them for life it's like
becoming fluid in Japanese no that's
that's like years of work becoming a
motorcycle driver two days ago I started
with learning how to solver
like the Japanese thing right that's a
slow burn that takes a long time yeah
but like I love those the idea that you
can do these like short courses or short
things and then you you walk out with a
lifetime skill yeah yeah it's really
cool absolutely and if you have the time
and the ability and the money to be able
to do it all right sure yeah because you
can you do courses in like it depends on
what type of license you want but you
can do like three to five days yeah no I
definitely want to do them and then you
can transfer to Japan yeah yeah for sure
for sick I want to write a holly that's
so [ __ ] awesome Holly's associate I
saw these dudes in Japan when we were
cycling in Hokkaido they had like they
were like uh motorcycling across Ohio
and it looks so [ __ ] fun it looks so
cool
I think it's fun because you're doing it
with the boys right yeah there's like
two of them doing it man I was hyped but
then if you have a certain license like
the best one you can have people ride
with you oh yeah yeah that would be
[ __ ] cool like Joey hop on the back
let's go by the way I did three days of
motorcycle training
you have to lean into the curve with me
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know I just
thought that that's really cool that'd
be fun no I understand I I I and I wanna
I really want to try and learn more of
these like skills that are that are very
like quick to acquire but a lifetime uh
you know yeah no I I totally agree with
that sentiment like you know again like
during the pandemic especially I was at
that point where I'm like what are like
some things that I could easily learn at
home that are gonna be completely
useless to me but it's just cool to say
that I can do it and like learning how
to solve a Rubik's Cube was like one of
them it's like it's not gonna [ __ ]
give you everyone have that pandemic
skill yeah it's like it's not going to
get me a job but you know it's it's a
cool bar trick now that I can do so [ __ ]
it you know whatever yeah
I think that would be like just awesome
and I I'm always wanting to improve
myself uh and learn new skills and I
think you know why not like and I don't
know why I decided I was like I kind of
want to learn motorcycle first that
feels very achievable very easy well not
easy but very very doable and also I get
to see my family at the same time so I
was like all right that sounds like a
good goal for sure yeah it'd be fun yeah
maybe they would do like car versus
train bus motorcycles we'll do that with
that that's right this is fun think
about the content as well we have so
much content out of this sure always the
content brain with you man no it's both
it's all it's like if you can if the
Venn diagram it fits everything that's
why am I not doing it yeah yeah like you
know what I mean I guess that's awesome
I get it yeah no I I I totally
understand and I totally understand that
that's just the way up
you're like I I hate this idea that
everything in [ __ ] life you need to
be super goddamn passionate about and
that like oh you have a good enough
reason to do something [ __ ] off maybe I
just wanted to [ __ ] do it maybe I
just want to do it maybe I'd rather try
it like yeah I don't know if I like
motorcycles I was never in the family
that did motorcycle I don't [ __ ] know
but I want to try it let me [ __ ] get
the noise has to be a first yeah like
that I just I hate this notion that you
have to have a good enough reason to do
anything for fun things oh oh you've
never saw an interest in surfing before
why are you surfing it's like [ __ ] off
maybe I just want to try it yeah what's
uh what's like the weirdest thing that
you like picked up or learned before
just like randomly
has there ever been anything like an
activity like a skill interpretive
damage have you actually I should break
down so I was like 12 oh [ __ ] I'm still
[ __ ] because everyone as a kid they
tried this like one weird thing like
every like everyone has this one weird
thing whether they're a kid or an adult
or something they and they've tried
something you know a weird activity that
they just never picked up again for
example because they grew up or they ran
out of time or something like that so
like for example I remember in like in
like University I did a year of like
ballroom and Latin America dancing
really yeah I was I I think like the
only reason I stopped was because third
year of unit I know I did two years ago
like third year of University had no
time to do it now I I think back and I
was like [ __ ] that was fun as hell man I
did uh I did Karate for three months
uh what's the one above white brown
brown yeah I did Karate as again as well
I got to Brown I got the brown and then
and then the training just got like it
just went like 10 levels High
yeah because I noticed I noticed with a
lot of these activities right with
karate or something you know it's it's
easy to like get into you know you you
have you hit a certain point maybe when
it's like brown belt where he's just
like I'm only casually doing this one
activity and then you will always hit
that wall where if you want to make
progress It's just like oh the time
investment Sully just jumps up tenfold
now I have to be dedicated yeah yeah
yeah yeah it goes from like being just a
casual fun activity to like a proper
hobby you know what I mean there's so
many hobbies like that like especially
when I was like in high school and [ __ ]
there was just so many things like that
where I'm like yo give it a go and then
I would get to the point where I'm like
okay I'm enjoying this and then that the
like I taught myself how to play flute
just randomly I never had an interest in
the instrument and I'm just like yo just
see if I can learn it and then I got
pretty good and then yeah and then I hit
that wall where it's like oh now I have
to start learning these like new [ __ ] I
I a lot of the times when you you know
you become an adult and you're working
you have a lot of time people just stop
learning stuff yeah and I find that
because they're content with where they
are right yeah and people also at least
this happened a lot in the UK people
would like make fun of you if you
started learning something new
um you know as an adult because they're
like because they were self-conscious
that they weren't really trying to
improve themselves or learn new skills
yeah and I hate that so [ __ ] much no
it's just you know again I think it's
it's not it's not even doing that I feel
like you got like if you did some in the
UK at least with my experience as an
adult if you did something that was just
outside of the circle of like what's
normal yeah or just outside of what they
perceive you as you know your character
then you would you know you would be
called out as being like why are you
doing this oh it's a phase it's a phase
yeah Australia was the exact same yeah
like why are you trying reach Japan it's
so far away yeah yeah yeah that's right
and I I feel like it's the same thing
with like learning as well because a lot
of adults I feel like why there's this
big stigma around oh you learn languages
for example better when you're a kid or
you just learn better when you're a kid
I think that's like complete [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's just that number one you
just run out of time to like learn
things because learning takes time you
know learning a new skill takes time but
I feel like you are just as capable as
an adult learning new things new skills
whenever you want to but the problem is
it's just harder to fit around your
adult schedule yeah that's that's saying
of like oh you can't teach an old dog
new tricks that's [ __ ] you
absolutely can it's just a matter of are
you willing to give it a go to begin
with because if you're not then yeah of
course you're not going to be a lot of
um there's a lot of studies been done
that like learning skills and
particularly language uh later on in
life is really beneficial to um like
stopping any kind of stopping but like I
I think it was like particularly
language if you learn language later on
life you were it would reduce the risk
of getting like Alzheimer's and stuff
like that yeah because it was it was
unlocking like a certain part of the
brain that you had well you're keeping
your brain active basically like
learning stuff and doing that is very
healthy
um whether it be just a Rubik's Cube or
learning a like flying a plane like yeah
all this stuff is great or even simple
stuff like you know uh playing chess or
like Mahjong and like like board games
that require a lot of like brain power
and thinking it's like yeah that's the
reason why so many like older people
play it is because they're keeping their
brains active and healthy yeah and it's
like that's super important at a certain
age obviously not at our age yet but
eventually we'll get to a point
hopefully if we survive that long where
you know we'll need activities like that
and we'll need to be curious enough to
be like all right what's something I can
do you know what's what's a new thing I
can learn what's something I can improve
on yeah because if you're just content
with the [ __ ] that you have over the 60
70 years that you've lived then you're
just gonna end up being like well
kind of [ __ ] bored now uh not much to
do brain empty I do want to be able to
drive every vehicle yeah I don't know
why all right all right what about my
James Bond moment where I gotta I gotta
steal every vehicle that get away you
know what I mean like I don't know I
just really like the idea of being able
to it would be cool drive a boat fly a
plane yeah motorcycle like do all this
cool [ __ ] I don't know why for no
particular you never have to worry about
no reason
yeah hypothetical question all right
we're not automatically hypothetical
question all right we're not on the
grinds anymore we're in retirement age
I'm in retirement age okay you have all
the free time in the world and you can
do anything you want what are you doing
I'll probably get a pilot license I
really want to [ __ ] fly a plane I
would travel to as many countries as I
can like just travel and then I'll do
something
I myself
it's like TSA [ __ ] please
I think I would start learning and
picking up more musical instruments I
really like I really you can do that now
I could I just like
I miss playing the guitar I think I I
could easily jam out with you dude I I
miss I miss playing it but you can learn
as well
if there's one musical instrument I've
always wanted to play and my probably my
favorite musical instrument is probably
the piano okay saxophone saxophones
dude you instantly get 10 times sexier
you do I just want to get to the point
where all I have to do is
that's all it's like that's the only
thing I can play piano has a certain
Elegance to it yeah there's just
something like that just like
mesmerizing about seeing someone God's
Asian side of the show
I don't know something about hearing
like some something about hearing like
someone who's just really good at the
time there's just something that just
moves me in a way that no other like
instrument can and every other
instrument has saxophone in your face
oh no if I have a sexism on my face
that's a different color you like
feeling bro I'm like yo
yeah there's a big difference between
chakra opening and bricked up just like
every time I talk to Kevin I remember
like when Kevin uh when I when I found
out Kevin was composing for like uh
rising of The Shield hero yeah and like
I've heard isekai soundtracks before
right and I was like let's see how Kevin
let's see what Kevin would do right and
like you know I watched the first few
episodes and it's just like kind of like
the generic kind of fancy things but now
like out of nowhere and it's one scene
he just breaks out the [ __ ] saxophone
I'm like [ __ ] hell Kevin yo I didn't
need to be breaked up in an Easter car
man Kevin please stop man holy [ __ ]
that's not the time now is not the time
Kevin you're a [ __ ] genius by the way
that saxophone
yeah I definitely would want to learn
more instruments as well yeah yeah again
there's like no there's no reason why
there's no deeper [ __ ] love it's just
I just I just give it a go something in
my head wants me to do that I don't know
I want to be like that cool dad or that
cool Uncle who's just like yeah what do
you want to do there's a lot of cool
things I can show you yeah yeah
yeah and that's why I totally get the
wanting to have every like driving
license
you're like boys you wanna we're gonna
fly I'll fly it even if it's something
that's like I'm never gonna like I might
use it once in my life like yeah I have
a forklift license no because like
yourself
you need a forklift driven yeah I gotta
turn up to the Amazon warehouse yeah
boys boys I can do that for you my time
has come boys step out of the way I
learned how to drive this thing 30 years
ago yeah because I have an uncle that
does have a pilot's license
um
it's expensive
you gotta have money yeah yeah and time
and yeah because uh I think he he lives
he lives in Australia and apparently
like
yeah yeah exactly so it's quite easy to
find a place to get your pilot's license
still takes a [ __ ] ton of time oh yeah
there's so much exams and stuff as well
like I'm [ __ ] jealous man because my
my nephew is also like in the process of
getting his his pilot's license and he's
[ __ ] 18 I'm like [ __ ] you man how'd
you get to be so cool when you're 18.
[ __ ] you that is such a bragging rate as
well at 18 yeah it's like yeah I can fly
a plane yeah yeah I remember when we
were I was in the University one time
and this guy he's on my course his dad
uh was a like a recreational pilot just
for fun yeah you did engineering or
something and um his dad would you know
sort of drive from North Wales also
South Wales to like North England it was
like four five six hours yeah depending
on where you go and he was just like oh
yeah no no my dad's gonna pick me up at
the local airport like it's a tiny
little strip and fly him back can you
believe that I was like God
this is so cool
like 40 30 minutes I'm like that's
[ __ ] up the only thing colder than
that is like you get to [ __ ] skip all
this traffic you no [ __ ] luggage fees
like you you know you just get to
[ __ ] go on the [ __ ] tarmac the
only thing just as cool as that is like
a helicopter license dude
yeah that would be epic yeah my dad's
coming to pick me up and they're
helicopter
it's like son where are you
[ __ ] bring the chopper out God I
don't know how it works I know that
I think helicopters are way more
expensive I think yeah to get the
license
to have a helicopter oh to have a house
yeah I'm sure really then a plane I
guess maybe they're not as common right
um yeah I mean like National planes are
I mean obviously sort of expensive I
think also just from engineering course
I remember this they they the way that
planes and airplanes are like um I need
to fact check this guy
um I think like a plane it's cons like
you know how like a car is Miles right
yeah you judge a car by like 10 000
miles yeah a plane is like the moment it
like is is done it starts ticking like
how how long it's allowed to like
operate without that stuff but I think a
helicopter is similar to uh to cars I
can't remember or it's miles there's
something something different about it I
remember the planes haven't used by date
yeah the planes literally have like a
the moment they're done they start
ticking on like okay you have to
maintenance them every x amount of
months or they're not allowed to fly
right I mean that makes sense I would
hope so
that's why that's why you know you lose
a lot of money when the plane is just
sitting there yeah
if you use a plane every single moment
it's like possible in the air it like
the way that it's checked and the way
that service is no different to if that
plane has been in a hangar with no use
at all right in terms of like how it's
cared for it needs to be like the same
kind of service
um so that's why a lot of the times when
the headlines like go go go go yeah use
it as much as you can because it's you
know this is [ __ ] expensive to keep
it playing yeah what about like uh what
about like a boat license I want a boat
license that's way more like a sailor's
license or uh you could sell you can
sell about you know like a yacht license
yeah a lot yeah well it's like a powered
yeah after a certain size I think yeah I
can't remember what it is I would
definitely go fishing more yeah [ __ ] man
don't listen to me it's very achievable
yeah I don't yeah I wonder if they
transfer from like other countries to
Japan I don't know if they do I know for
sure because that'd be hype that would
be hard to get my boat license in the UK
be like hide your hand
give me the yard because basically tldr
if you come from a foreign country get
your licenses in that foreign country
and then transfer them to Japan because
it sucks in Japan yeah and it's funnily
enough a lot of license are transferable
you know except for Americans
so let's do an exams yeah you have to do
it you can transfer it you've just an
examine a test I'll shoot your test
still oh wow the test only in Japanese
which [ __ ] sucks